one great exercise early in the morning
it's better than doing it this afternoon
when it's going to be up around 100
degrees and we've got those southwest
winds south
south maybe even southeast today up to
25 miles an hour beautiful as we look
out to that area the northwest valley
temperatures in the upper 70s up there
summerlin in the mid 70s downtown still
at 83.
85 in green valley you just have not
been able to cool off overnight this
morning 76 at sunrise mountain nellis at
77 mountains edge in the mid 70s and 77
for seven hills it was a little breezy
earlier this morning at red rock but the
winds have calmed down a lot 69 out at
red rock it would be fine getting a bike
ride in or a good job or hike this
morning if you want to head out there a
little cooler this morning in that part
of the of the valley 78 degrees in
mesquite 71 indian springs we've got 60
in caliani 63 up in ely tonopah at 60
degrees and 61 in reno 75 for sandy
valley mid 70's for perron so here's
what's going on for the next few days
dry and breezy afternoons this should
last through friday temperatures just a
little bit below normal for the next
couple of days then get that ac tuned up
if you haven't done it yet for the
summer you're like oh yeah i haven't
used it much get the filters changed and
you might get a service call because
we've got a lot of heat coming next week
we're looking at temperatures that could
be up to 110 plus for most of next week
we're going to get a ridge of high
pressure building in
over the west in the desert southwest
it's going to really intensify our
temperatures much like what they're
getting right here in the mid-south
through the deep south if temperatures
don't hit a hundred where they have
excessive heat warnings for wichita and
st louis it's gonna feel like a hundred
plus with the excessive humidity that's
what they get all summer long heat and
humidity thunderstorms rolling around
that big ridge of high pressure
we'll be looking at
heat intensifying as high pressure kind
of positions itself over towards the
four corners and that will bring us
south southwest to southeast breezes
they're going to be switching around a
little bit over the next couple of days
101 today 102 tomorrow and then sliding
right back to normal to finish the week
at 105 but look at the weekend 107 108
and next week up near 110. ouch